un hommage pour ne pas oublier ce
vendredi 13 octobre Dominique Bernard
professeur de lettres était assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste au sein de
son lycée à haras ce lundi 16 octobre de
nombreux recueillements étaient
organisés par les communes ivelinoise
pour saluer sa
[Musique]
mémoire am Manil et àot ils était une
cinquantaine d'habitants au pied de
l'hôtel de ville un besoin de se
retrouver ensemble contre la barbe
ai en cette journée qui commémorait les
3 ans de l'assassinat du professeur
Samuel Patti à Conflant saint-onorine je
suis parent d'élève j'ai deux enfants
dont une jeune fille de 14 ans qui est
scolarisée au collège à manie et parler
de ça avec nos enfants bah c'est super
important hein c'est la transmission bon
elle se pose quand même pas mal de
questions aussi hein bon est-ce que je
suis en sécurité l'école l'éducation
nationale dans notre pays ben est un
socle qui permet de transmettre un
certain nombre de valeurs et notamment
toutes les valeurs qui font notre vivre
ensemble les questions de liberté
d'égalité la fraternité et puis la
laïcité à plaisir les habitants se sont
rassemblés au côté de la Mer de la ville
pour combattre la peur et soutenir le
corps enseignant on a besoin de sentir
qu'on est tous ensemble le rassemblement
fait aussi et ben la sérénité apporte
aussi cette force parce que le
rassemblement il peut être violent il
peut ê combatif mais nous on est dans le
combat de la paix je me sens concerné
parce que déjà je suis maman et je suis
grand-mère et mon gendre est prof aussi
donc je j'ai peur j'ai peur pour ma
famille d'être tous rassemblés ça nous
fait du bien on a besoin de se
rassembler pour vivre ensemble ces
moments-là des rassemblements se sont
tenus dans la plupart des communes de
saint-quanttin en iveline le président
de l'aglomération Jean-Michel Fourgous a
lui choisi de suivre la minute de
silence dans une classe de l'école de la
nouvel Amsterdam à
hlencour